in this video we're going to give an
overview of the types of markets that
you might encounter in an economics
class and we're going to get a little
bit precise with our language because
you'll hear words like perfect
competition or monopoly or oligopoly a
lot in economics and frankly even in
your broader life now before we even go
into those terms i will differentiate
between what's sometimes referred to as
a product
market
and other markets that are referred to
as
resource resource
markets
now product market is a market where the
output of that market what the market is
producing or what it's buying and
selling it is something that people will
consume and it doesn't just have to be a
physical product it could also be some
type of a service so examples of product
markets it could be
the market for shirts
it could be cars
or it could even be a service it could
be tax preparation
tax preparation these would all be
product markets because it's something
that people would consume
and i would call this consumer tax
preparation not business tax preparation
so this is consumer tax preparation now
based on my clarification you might
guess what a resource market is all
about these are markets for the inputs
into other products or into the
production of other even resources so
these would be your famous inputs of or
factors of production so it could be for
example the market of labor
it could be something like farmland
where farmland is used to produce
something else it could be the market
for capital goods maybe robots for
factories
but either way whether we're talking
about product markets or resource
markets we can think about them in broad
terms based on how many players there
are in the market and how differentiated
the players are on the market and how
much control they have over the price
and how are the barriers to entry
so let's set up a spectrum here to
explore that a little bit
so i will set up a spectrum now the
extreme end of the spectrum right over
here when you only have one player
one player in the market in
the market or actually let me just say
one firm
because players not really clear what
i'm talking about whether i'm talking
about a buyer seller one firm
in market
and let's say many buyers
many
buyers
you are probably familiar with what we
call this market or what we would call
this firm it has a monopoly
it has a monopoly named for a famous
game and because that whole point of
that game is to try to be that last firm
standing the firm that owns all of the
real estate now what are the situations
that would describe a monopoly well a
monopoly is a situation where you have
very high one could argue insurmountable
barriers to entry so very high
high
barriers
to entry
and monopolies can sometimes be
controversial but they're not
necessarily illegal in fact in many
countries a monopoly can be granted to a
firm through things like the
intellectual property or through patents
for example a drug company if it
discovers a cure for a drug or something
to maintain a drug well they might be
granted a monopoly for that pill for
some period of time and the government
does that so that they could recoup
their investment in all of the r d that
they actually produced
what often is illegal in a lot of
countries is if a firm misuses its
monopoly power
but anyway now let's go to the other
extreme
let's imagine a situation where instead
of high barriers to entry there's no
barriers
no barriers
to
entry
and let's say that there's no
differentiation
and you have many players
so many
or let me write many firms i keep
wanting to say players but that doesn't
make it that clear and actually let me
say many firms and many buyers
and many buyers now this is a state that
will often study in our economics class
we'll call it perfect competition
perfect
competition
in a perfect competition world the firms
are essentially have to be price takers
they take whatever the market price is
and we've used that assumption in a lot
of situations in a monopoly on the other
side they could be the price setters
they're the only player in that market
now in general when anything is
described as perfect it's usually
theoretical and so is perfect
competition there's no markets that i
can think of that are perfectly perfect
but i can think of ones that are close
for say some agricultural commodities so
say the sugar market
so the market for sugar might be pretty
close to perfect competition there could
be many firms those would be the farmers
the suppliers
would be many buyers obviously who want
sugar there would be some barriers to
entry you would need to know how to grow
sugar you would need suitable land for
growing sugar but there's a lot of
farmers who might be able to swap out
either sugarcane or beet which is where
most sugar comes from
with soybean or vice versa so they can
change which crops they they plant and
and generally speaking there's not much
differentiation whether you get sugar
from one farmer or another so sugar
would be pretty close to perfect
competition and it is the case for a lot
of agricultural commodities that you
they do have to be price takers there is
just a market price that the individual
farmers to say well i actually i want to
charge a little bit more for that sugar
because they won't be able to they're
just going to have to take whatever the
price is in the market now as you can
imagine there's a lot of other types of
markets that are in between these
extremes
closer to a monopoly and similar to a
monopoly in a lot of ways is a situation
where you have only a handful of firms
and that's referred to oligopoly
oligopoly
and this is a situation where you still
have high barriers
so high bar high
barriers
to entry
you might have a handful of firms so a
few
a few firms and you still have many
buyers
and examples of oligopolies this could
be things like the aircraft industry
aircraft
where there's huge barriers of entry you
need to deploy a lot of capital billions
of dollars you might have to get
government approval and so that's why
especially for large aircraft you only
have a few firms that can produce like
boeing or airbus those really large
aircraft even in certain cases
automobiles sometimes computer
manufacturers things that have very very
high barriers to entry
now if we go a little bit further to the
left you get a situation that's known as
monopolistic competition
monopolistic it's fun to say
competition
and this you could view as right in
between depending on what you're
thinking about so this is a situation
where there's low barriers to entry
low
low barriers to entry
there's many firms many firms
but you do have differentiation you do
have
differentiation so you can tell the
product of one firm for another and i
can think of many in fact most
industries i can think of fall roughly
in the monopolistic
area although there's we just mentioned
some oligopolies and monopolies but
examples of monopolistic competition i
can imagine to be things like
cereal breakfast cereals in the
breakfast cereal industry
there's many many firms there's
generally low barriers if you there's
some barriers but they're pretty low if
you want to start a cereal company a lot
of folks might be able to do it but
there is some differentiation some
people some say hey our cereal is more
delicious and it's sweeter while others
say our cereal is is more nutritious and
they build a brand and they do marketing
etc etc and because there is some
differentiation there is a little bit
more ability for the individual players
unlike eight in perfect competition
there's a little bit more ability for
them to dictate their price they might
say hey we're a premium product people
think we're healthier so we might be
able to charge a little bit more you can
almost imagine that they have their own
unique demand curve because of that
differentiation you can imagine the
market in something like well
shirts that's another example
where a lot of folks can produce shirts
but some people might be able to
differentiate themselves they're more
stylish there's better quality they
advertise they build a brand and so once
again that would be monopolistic
competition so anyway the big picture
here is really just for you to get
familiar with these words what do they
mean and in what context or what will
they imply about the differentiation or
the number of firms and actually before
i leave i'll throw out one other word
that you'll hear a little bit less than
what i just talked about and it sounds
like monopoly but it is monopsony and
i'm going to do this in a unique color
here let me see i haven't done anything
in this salmon yet
sunny which you won't hear it as much as
monopoly and it's really the opposite
situation instead of one supplier and
many buyers a monopsony is one big buyer
and many suppliers so for example if you
have one big box store in a small town
and so they're the only employer in that
town they might have monopsony in the
labor market where they're the only
people who can hire
and there's a lot of people who are
looking for jobs but we could talk more
about that in other videos